we are um unfortunately
potentially approaching a very
dangerous period um not
ideologically but in a very sort of
literal
and and pragmatic sense a a dangerous
period what could be dangerous
for many americans uh because president
donald trump
in his latest series of rage tweets
amplified a message
reportedly from one of his fans that
things are soon to escalate
and it could be a dangerous moment in
america which of course is likely to
have the effect
of planting that idea in his followers
and actually making it so a
self-fulfilling prophecy of sorts
so let me back up and kind of give you
the genesis of all of this yesterday
morning
after a couple of days of relative calm
on twitter and i used that phrase very
very loosely
um donald trump amplified
some dangerous messages and also sent
some messages
of his own attacking joe biden attacking
republican governor brian kemp
and this now is of getting to be
extremely concerning over what is going
to be a
five or six week period of this nonsense
i predict it started with a sort of
strange all-capital letters tweet where
donald trump said
merely wisdom and courage very strange
thing to say
and then he he quoted an unnamed fan
supposedly from one of his rallies as
reported supposedly by propaganda
network oan
and this is where donald trump amplifies
the idea of a dangerous moment with huge
escalations saying quote
and this is quote quote this is me
quoting trump quoting oan
quoting a trump supporter people are
upset
they have a right to be georgia not only
supported trump in 2016 but now
that's untrue of course this is the only
state in the deep south that went for
biden
have they lost their minds and yeah i
mean biden one that's it
this is going to escalate dramatically
this is a very dangerous moment
in our history the fact that our country
is being stolen a coup is taking place
in front of our eyes and the public
can't take this anymore
now that's all untrue and trump quotes
a trump fan at a georgia rally per oan
and then says
bad after that donald trump went after
republican georgia governor brian kemp
why because kemp won't illegally steal
the election for trump
kemp is no good guy i really want people
to understand this
when when i've been saying this week
kemp doesn't seem willing to try
to steal georgia for trump um
i believe kemp kemp is horrible kemp
participated in voter suppression
in the very election in which he was a
candidate for governor
against stacey abrams kemp has overseen
the continued purging of voter rolls and
everything else that we've been talking
about
and i wouldn't even put it past kemp to
try to steal georgia
if doing so would give trump the
presidency what what
may be going on here is kemp realizes
even
if i try to fraudulently steal georgia
for trump
trump still doesn't win it just reduces
the number of electoral votes
by which joe biden wins and so listen
kemp's no good guy but trump's furious
with him because kemp won't try to steal
it for him
trump tweeting how does governor brian
kemp allow
certification of votes without verifying
signatures
and despite the recently released tape
of ballots being stuffed remember that
those tapes have been completely
debunked
his poll numbers has have dropped like a
rock
he is finished as governor i have no i
mean listen
uh as we spoke about yesterday with
benjamin dixon
there's a lot of republican infighting
in georgia this may
all damage in the end calculation
the final math this may hurt brian kemp
or it may not with georgia republicans
we don't know
but it's certainly not clear at this
time and of course most of these tweets
flagged by twitter as being misleading
or disputed
and then donald trump merely calling on
the supreme court to steal the election
for him saying quote
the supreme court has a chance to save
our
country capital c country from the
greatest
capital e election abuse in the history
of the united states 78 percent of the
people
feel know the election was rigged
so when trump chooses to quote
and amplify some alleged follower who's
saying
this is about to escalate and this will
become a dangerous moment for the united
states
it's very very dangerous for trump to do
now trump can hide behind
i didn't say it i was quoting a fan
but it's fanning the flames when the
president does this
it's dog whistling when the president
does this and this could get very ugly
very quickly
and i have no idea what trump supporters
are willing to do what are they capable
of
as they are inevitably seeing i mean
it's happening daily every lawsuit
getting tossed
each day trump continues to claim he won
and each day leads us to nothing other
than being one day closer to joe biden
being sworn in as president
on january 20th so it is scary
and um i get emails you know two three
four emails a day not dozens like when i
you know say the wrong thing but two
three four emails a day from people who
are saying listen i live in
this red state i'm worried about this
or that because these people are furious
these people
literally believe the things that donald
trump is saying they're not
you know they don't interpret i was
robbed as i should have won but i didn't
they interpret i was robbed as specific
democrats
manipulated votes and stole and
cheated and hacked and all this
different stuff
and that the will of the people was that
donald trump would win they literally
believe that that's what trump is saying
and who knows what they are potentially
willing to do
um we all we can do is follow it and see
and hope for the best
if you are anything like me you probably
aren't thrilled with the idea of going
into a doctor's office right now
and thankfully there's a practical and
affordable way
to take control of your health and get
personalized
care from the comfort of your home it's
a service called
steady md they're one of our sponsors
you take a quiz
you get matched with a licensed primary
care physician
who understands your health needs you
have a one hour video call with your new
doctor
you establish a meaningful relationship
with them and after that
your doctor is available to you anytime
by text phone or video chat this is not
a random doctor on call
each doctor at steady md has a limited
number of patients so they actually have
time
to listen to you you get the personal
attention that you deserve
they can do almost everything an
in-person doctor can do
perform medical evaluations talk to you
about health concerns
send prescriptions to your home or local
pharmacy
and anything they can't do online
they'll quickly set you up with
an in-person provider to do things like
blood tests as an example
you don't need insurance it's only 99
bucks a month with no other fees or
copays
there are so many practical advantages
to using steady md for primary care
and it's also so much more affordable
go to steadymd.com pacman to take the
free quiz
see which doctor is right for you i took
their quiz they matched me with a doctor
who specializes in my particular health
needs and situation the doctor they gave
me
is a really perfect fit for me and my
medical needs
there's no risk no commitment to get
started just click the link right
underneath this video